um
this is not good hey everyone i'm abby
sharp welcome to abby's kitchen
[Music]
today's video is sponsored by bill barr
and we'll be reviewing lifestyle
youtuber and new mom sam oscarol but
first let me tell you about my sponsor
build bar
so
you guys know i'm saying it and i am
saying it again
these bars are really
really really tasty
and i don't usually like protein bars at
all because i don't like chalk
masquerading as a health food but
i love these bars like they taste like a
chocolate bar
but they have protein in them so
yeah
winning
today's little snack time
pleasure
a little afternoon delight
let's go tropical today
wow coconut
so 17 grams protein
feeling that
[Music]
tastes like the vacation that i am
definitely not having this year
but this would be so good like on yogurt
or in oatmeal or sometimes what i like
to do is melt it in the microwave for
like 10 seconds
put a little whipped cream on top
oh my gosh that is killer coconut
whipped cream
next level and i usually have one before
bed like
every day but if i were to do this as a
post-workout snack i would definitely
want to pair it with some source of
carbs like fruit oats toast whatever but
if you want to check these out yourself
check out the link in my description and
use my promo code abby sharp15 for 15
off of your order
now before we get into it feel free to
pause the screen or look at the
description to check out my disclaimer
including a trigger warning to those
with current or previous experiences
with disordered eating so of course feel
free as always to skip this video if
it's not supportive to your journey
and if you are new here do not forget to
subscribe to this channel and ring that
little bell so that you do not ever miss
out
on a video ever
never never never be the first one here
i like to see it also note that i film
these wedding a day videos well in
advance so this is not necessarily her
most up-to-date
diet or up-to-date display of what she
eats in fact she actually posted a brand
new one this morning right before we
went to start taping but we really want
to focus in on her kind of postpartum
belly tips and her gut health tips so i
really hope you enjoy this review
all right let's get into it
one of the first things that's so
important that i neglect but it's such a
simple thing is warm lemon water have
that first thing in the morning you've
just been sleeping your body is
dehydrated why go right to coffee that's
going to make it even worse okay so
let's debunk this for a hot minute
one you guys know what i'm gonna say but
there is
nothing magical about lemon water
it's water that's flavored with a little
bit of vitamin c so as much as any
source of water can hydrate you and
promote regularity
lemon water is of course good for your
gut second is coffee really dehydrating
no not really
yes caffeine is a mild diuretic which in
theory would increase urination and
cause you to lose more fluid but it
actually doesn't work like that because
this isn't a caffeine pill
this is caffeine in water
so you're not likely to lose more fluid
through urine than you're taking in by
drinking the caffeinated drink and i
mean it's even possible that the cup of
coffee could potentially help hydrate
you
not do the opposite
now is straight up lemon water better as
a hydration option
yes obviously
yes it is
but you don't need to obsess over which
one you drink first in the name of
hydration
also this isn't something she mentioned
but i want to take this time to bring up
something that i get asked about a lot
which is regarding whether or not coffee
first thing in the morning increases
cortisol
so there are a lot of tick tocks going
around suggesting that you want to delay
your morning cup until like mid morning
when your cortisol levels are naturally
a little bit lower so it's not to
exacerbate the stress response but we
actually have no evidence to support
that suggestion
and more importantly the cortisol
boosting effects of coffee
are hugely diminished if your body is
accustomed to drinking it so if you're
having coffee every day even if it is
first thing in the morning on an empty
stomach you're unlikely seeing any huge
dangerous effects on cortisol levels so
one of my friends turned me on to the
seed probiotics is good for gut health
is because it's going to add in good
bacteria the more backed up you get the
more bloated you'll feel the more
uncomfortable you'll feel and it
actually turns toxic in your body that
you have to be going regulars okay so a
few things i want to chat about with
this
now i have looked at this seed probiotic
and i think it looks great it's heavily
tested so that's a plus in my books and
yes having a varied strong microbiome is
really important for regularity and gut
health and this particular supplement
not only has the probiotic which is the
bacteria but it also is a prebiotic
which feeds the good bacteria a source
of beneficial fiber
as we know fiber does help you poop so
yes we like
now as for sam's suggestion that the
poop in your body turns toxic
there is this common myth that
constipation causes the body to absorb
poisonous substances in stools leading
to diseases like arthritis asthma and
colon cancer
there's no evidence that stools produce
toxins or that colon cleansing or
laxatives or enemas can prevent cancer
or other diseases
constipation itself is not considered a
disease it's a symptom
so if you are constipated definitely
speak to your doctor about some ways to
determine the root cause
rather than just trying to make yourself
poop once we get back in that's when i
make my coffee the new coconut nespresso
pod is amazing and then i add in
collagen collagen actually repairs your
gut lining you should youtube dr axe and
he talks all about the benefits of
collagen with your gut health and then
i've been loving the chobani sweet cream
creamer
all right so i'ma stick to my rule that
coffee is free game in the world of my
wedding day reviews but i do want to
quickly talk about collagen
uh first of all dr axe is not a credible
source of nutrition information
he makes a ton of unsubstantiated claims
including promoting frankincense for
cancer
mushroom capsules for anxiety and a
bunch of other essential oils for
alzheimer's and dementia
and you cannot market products to treat
cure or alleviate symptoms of diseases
without fda approval and that my friends
is not something that dr x has or anyone
else in this case so yeah
not a fan but anyways
everyone and their pseudo doctor seems
to be adding collagen to their coffee
these days and while there is some early
evidence suggesting that collagen
supplements may help to improve skin
health and joint health
when it comes to repairing gut lining or
leaky gut
not so much there's just no good
scientific evidence to date to support
this suggestion
or even the diagnosis of leaky gut but
that's a whole other video in itself
but in fact some collagen supplements
may even have a negative effect on
digestion with some people
as some do report uncomfortable feelings
of like fullness and heartburn but even
though taking collagen appears to be
totally safe and benign for most people
you might as well save your money and
get the same benefit from eating more
vitamin c and protein containing foods
or really any protein supplement on the
market since these are the precursors to
collagen production in the body
and when we're talking about gut health
specifically sticking to protein-rich
foods for your daily dose of collagen
may even offer some additional benefits
for your gut especially when coming from
probiotic containing protein sources
like yogurt and kefir as well as beans
and legumes which provide that happy gut
fiber having warm meals throughout the
day cooked meals can be really helpful
in healing on your gut okay so
interestingly there is new animal
research suggesting that cooked food may
positively alter the gut microbiome and
promote nutrient absorption better than
let's say raw food however more research
is definitely needed in this area and it
is still unclear how this research
translates to the microbiome of a human
i also think that the recommendation to
prioritize warm food for gut health may
be rooted in aerobatic practices which
suggests that hot foods can improve
digestion and circulation
however in ayurvedic practices a hot
food is not actually dependent on the
temperature of the food rather some
foods are considered to be hot based on
the supposed effect that it has in the
body
so even something like ice cream could
be considered a hot food because it's
thought to induce heat in the body
i got the answers man confusing i know
but either way we really don't have
enough good solid research to suggest
that only eating warm foods makes any
significant difference when it comes to
digestion as it mostly just depends on
the type of food that you're eating
more so than the specific temperature
it's being served at
so for example a warm pureed soup may be
easier to digest compared to a warm
cooked steak with roasted potatoes and
veggies
so even though they might be the exact
same temperature
they would actually be digested a bit
differently because the soup is already
partially pre-digested which would
therefore require a lot less work by the
body
on the other hand the very same soup may
be more easily digested by one person
than somebody else just based on their
individual tolerance levels and their
unique gut microbiome but this is
basically just my long long long winded
way of saying that the temperature of
foods
really won't make a huge significant
impact on your gut health compared to
other more significant factors like food
type and preparation methods i like to
make my snacks cute we can portion
control a lot better when we put it all
out like if i were to just go sit on the
couch with these i would just eat the
whole thing you don't want to eat a
million times a day and when you stop
eating and give yourself space and give
yourself time to digest your body can
start to break down that food and it can
also work on other things like cell
turnover people even like to do this for
anti-aging benefit how good does this
look so i have the peaches cherries
crackers
burrata so this snack screams summertime
and i am here for it we have a great
hunger crushing combo with the crackers
and fruit offering up some carbs along
with the protein and fat from the
burrata which looks totally divine i am
loki obsessed with burrata i mean i
don't know if you've seen my instagram
stories but burrata on toast is my new
weekend obsession i honestly can only
afford to do it like once a week cause
it's like 13 a ball here but oh my gosh
so worth it as for portioning if you are
someone who tends to eat while
distracted it can be really easy to
totally zone out of your fullness
signals and find your way like to the
bottom of the cracker box
so putting your snack in a bowl or a
plate or in this case like a beautiful
instagramable wooden platter which feels
hella unrealistic as a mom
rather than just eating out of the box
is a really good tool to help you check
in with your hunger so that way when you
finish your portion and you check in
with yourself and you determine that
you're maybe still looking for more you
can easily add more to the bowl or plate
this to me isn't about restriction it's
about mindfulness and also about
avoiding distraction when you eat it
just gives you those checkpoints to help
yourself become more accountable and
more in tune with your true needs as for
her thoughts on fasting or like avoiding
grazing while a 2018 review suggested
that fasting may help to promote cell
turnover the majority of the research we
have to date has been done on animals or
in test tubes so similar to the whole
hot food cold food debate we really
don't have a ton of great solid
understanding of how this research
translates into humans now what i think
that she may be referring to in this
clip but she doesn't say it is what we
call the migratory motor complex or mmc
now i talked about the mmc briefly in my
sibo video right here but in short the
migratory motor complex is kind of like
a big broom that helps to sweep food
particles through the digestive tract
every 130 minutes or so
this is literally the most legit form of
cleansing our body does
and you don't need green juice to make
it happen
but basically over time if we never give
our body the opportunity to do this
clean sweep because we're putting little
bites of food in our mouth all day as
long as as we tend to do when we're moms
bacteria can potentially pool there and
it can affect the integrity of our
microbiome so if this is her rationale
for trying to space out her meals and
snacks every few hours
this does make good sense now i also
think it's worth reminding everyone that
your body is extremely intelligent
if it needs more food it will tell you
if it needs less food it will tell you
if it needs rest it will tell you
so if you constantly find yourself
always need to be constantly snacking
and grazing all day long because you're
just not satisfied
it might be a good indicator that your
meals need to be more balanced or that
you just need to eat more food in that
meal
and if you're trying to space your meals
out it's really worth collecting that
data that hey you know i need more food
at that lunch meal or snack in order to
make it to my next meal without getting
ravenous and just putting everything in
my mouth that's what she said
let's see what she's making for lunch
i'm reheating this chicken soup that i
made in my last video soup doesn't sound
super summery but it's great on your gut
and then my neighbor invited me over to
pick some kale so i added it in my soup
i got the idea from gwyneth paltrow's
book so yes and no to soup being good
for your gut
generally speaking cooking your
vegetables a la soup is gonna be a lot
easier on digestion compared to eating
them raw because those tough fibers are
already somewhat broken down for you
and generally speaking i would say that
a chicken noodle soup is relatively easy
on the gut unless of course you have a
sensitive gut to certain fodmaps uh
since some of the big fodmap triggers
like garlic onions and celery are kind
of the base of any chicken soup she also
added in some pretty big pieces of raw
kale at the end there and didn't really
give it any time to cook down and soften
so if she does have a sensitive tummy i
would at least cook down that kale or
mince it up really really fine into
small pieces so that it cooks down
faster in the heat
it's also worth noting that really
brothy soups can easily tip the scales
into being quite high in sodium which
can also lead to sodium retention and
bloating now this is not exactly the
same bloating that you would experience
if you had ibs
but it still could feel uncomfortable in
the gut but i do really like that we
have some protein in the chicken fiber
and carbs in the noodles and veg
loving that right there
but i do think we could bump up the fat
and calories generally
i mean it is a very light meal here so
pairing this with like a piece or two of
toast with some olive oil or some
avocado on top would be a really nice
way to bump that up i am grilling the
zucchini with some garlic add in the
asparagus for the last three minutes i
did want to make a little salmon on the
side because there was just no protein
fresh oregano a purple onion and then i
put my own twist on it by adding little
cherry tomatoes put it all in a bowl and
you have the perfect summer salad primal
kitchen balsamic which is a healthier no
sugar added you can find this on thrive
market mix it all in and i served it
with salmon okay so i have to agree with
sam that looks like the most delicious
perfect summer salad
we've got some beautiful seasonal
veggies in there like asparagus zucchini
and cherry tomatoes we've got some carbs
from the pasta and some protein and
healthy fats from the salmon i mean i
really don't know
how you could go wrong with this now
before we wrap things up with the stats
and the recommendations i want to take a
quick look at sam's postpartum weight
loss strategy that i'm not eating for
two first trimester you're eating the
same the second trimester you want to
increase it by a snack third trimester
you want to increase it by a meal pretty
much stuck to that diet i had ice cream
sometimes some days we would just have
pizza and then other days i'd be eating
super clean it's not like i ate 100
clean 24 7 but i was definitely 80 20.
okay so i like that sam is poking a few
holes in the whole eating for two myth
because as she said the caloric
requirements during pregnancy is pretty
much equivalent to adding like an extra
snack in your second trimester and an
extra meal in your third trimester it's
not exactly a situation where you've got
to double your grocery bill
but ultimately these are just
suggestions and some people may find
that they actually need more calories to
feel satisfied so it's really important
to let your body be your guide i also
want to remind folks that while your
pregnancy app might suggest that you're
supposed to gain a perfect pound per
week
in real life
it doesn't have to look like that
in my first pregnancy i barely gained
anything until like the last two months
and in my second pregnancy i gained
almost all of my weight in the first
trimester and gained pretty much nothing
in the last month
so every person and pregnancy is
different
and i also think it's great that she
tried to create some balance for herself
by prioritizing nutrient-dense foods to
help support her baby while also leaving
some room in there for foods she just
enjoys
however i just gotta say i'm obviously
not a fan of verbiage like clean or 80
20.
it's dated it's boring let's move on the
first is when i got home from the
hospital i did have a belly band and it
also helps flush out the extra fluid so
it's great here that the belly band
seemed to work for sam
uh even though there is no real solid
research supporting the use of belly
bands postpartum anecdotally some women
may find that they help to support their
core muscles postpartum as was the case
for sam
however belly bands are still a
contemporary fix so i would still
recommend that women who experience
diastasis recti consult with their
pelvic floor physiotherapist as you
really want to focus on dr friendly
exercises as for her comment about it
flushing out excess fluid
in case no one prepared you for this
expect to sweat a lot postpartum i
actually thought that i was dying after
my first pregnancy because i was soaking
my sheets every night
so this isn't so much
likely to do with the belly band
it's just a shift in hormones and your
body getting rid of the excess water
that held onto during pregnancy
but honestly i also think it's a bit
strange to me that she included this tip
in her video on how she lost her
postpartum belly because belly bands are
not a weight loss tool
they are meant to support your core as a
rehabilitation tool not to magically
de-bloat cleanse reshape detoxify or
permanently whittle your waist i did
breastfeed i'm actually still
breastfeeding i'm getting close to being
done breastfeeding we are in the weaning
process but a lot of people told me oh
yeah that helps you lose weight it helps
you burn calories and all that yeah i
think there's a huge expectation that
breastfeeding will automatically result
in extreme weight loss postpartum and
that makes total sense when we consider
that breastfeeding or pumping burns
around 20 calories per ounce
however in real life
breastfeeding doesn't result in weight
loss for all women across the board i
actually have a whole blog post on this
one but some women like me
may actually gain some weight from
breastfeeding postpartum so there's a
number of potential reasons for this
like an increase in prolactin which is
the fat storing hormone cortisol from
lack of sleep and stress and of course
the increase in appetite resulting in
eating more
ultimately despite what aunt karen says
the current evidence suggests that
postpartum lifestyle factors like sleep
and diet are likely much more indicative
of weight loss outcomes than
breastfeeding the fab four smoothie i
found be well by kelly so the fab four
smoothie is protein fat greens and fiber
and you can just pick whatever you want
to do protein powder almond butter
greens
non-dairy milk and flax seeds as my
fiber all right so this is really a
similar concept to my hunger crushing
combo which is really just a way to
balance your meals with protein fat and
fiber rich carbs to help keep you full
now while you could totally use a source
of carbs for fiber here by adding in
some fruit it looks like sam is making
her smoothie kind of like low carb by
opting for some flaxseed instead and i
know she says that this tastes super
good and hearty to her
but personally i
need fruit in my smoothie but to each
their own if it works for her it works
for me then if you must add fruit in
your smoothie she says just keep it to a
fourth cup when you start your day with
a lot of sugar it raises your insulin
you're just trying to keep up with that
all day so you have a smoothie and then
you're hungry like an hour later 30
minutes later ah got it
now we know the rationale for the
fruitless smoothie and it's a bit of a
swing and a mess
so the satiety factor of the fab four
combo would still stand even if you
threw a little fruit into the mix which
by the way would also add saturating
fiber not only that but the carbs from
the fruit would add a boost of energy
and that would be sustained from the
protein and the fat and the fiber
content in the smoothie
in other words adding a little bit of
fruit to your smoothie wouldn't spike
your blood sugar levels like sam
suggests
sure it might not be a keto smoothie but
sam isn't strictly keto anyways and it
really wouldn't break her weight loss
goals either
seeing as a half cup of berries has just
24 calories
so yeah
this just seems like an unnecessarily
restrictive rule to me
i started adding some low carb dinners
into my diet so i am 100 not low carb
however i do add low carb lunches or low
carb dinners if i'm eating a lot of
carbs i notice that i have more water
weight i bloat more i mean i guess going
semi low carb would also explain the
fruitless smoothie even though again
half a cup of berries is generally
allowed even on some modest keto diet so
i just feel like it's obnoxiously strict
but that bloating she mentioned is
likely just a little extra water
and that's because when we store excess
carbs as glycogen we store them with
about three to four times their weight
in water
and this is why often when people go
super low carb they lose a lot of weight
really fast and this is just the initial
loss in water storage not necessarily
fat regardless if this way of eating
feels best to sam it totally works for
me
i'm just really glad that sam doesn't
seem to be 100 all in
on the keto low carb life especially
because it's unclear whether or not
ketosis is actually safe while
breastfeeding
early research on animals suggests that
ketones do appear in breast milk and
that breast milk from keto mom rodents
was insufficient in nutrition volume or
both resulting in growth retardation
now this is rats not human so please do
not freak out we still need a lot more
research to determine the risk in humans
like us and also sam isn't even keto so
i'm really not worried about the safety
of her milk but i just wanted to flag
one of the many reasons why carbs and
also getting enough calories more
specifically can be important for our
growing babes now aside from the water
with the carbs causing bloating
it's also possible that some of the
carbs she enjoys may be higher in
fodmaps and therefore they may be
causing some digestive distress now i've
got a whole video on fodmaps which you
can check out right here but if this is
the case i strongly advise working with
a registered dietitian to determine the
specific triggers and quantities that
are an issue for her i did go dairy free
my daughter had colic and she was just
crying a lot we would do gripe water and
that would help a lot too grape water
was like a lifesaver goat cheeses or
goat milks i would occasionally have i
noticed that the weight was flying off
being dairy free because there's only so
many options you can have i highly
recommend just going dairy free now so
that it gets out of your system um maybe
like the last trimester going dairy free
okay so if you are unfamiliar with colic
thank the heavens because it's literal
hell
uh baby e had colic for the first three
and a half months and honestly looking
back
i'm not sure how i survived that one
but basically babies with colic
experience intense crying spells for
several hours of the day for no apparent
reason aka a new parent's worst
mom we don't exactly know what causes
colic as it's likely multi-factorial but
for some babies dye is thought to
potentially play a role
however the research on whether or not a
breastfeeding mom needs to go dairy free
is admittedly mixed at best some
research has found that some infants may
respond positively to a low allergen or
dairy free maternal diet while other
research has found no reduction in the
rate of colic when breastfeeding mothers
went dairy-free i consulted with my
colleague chrissy carroll who's an
expert in this area and she said that
most women can safely enjoy dairy while
breastfeeding and that there is no
reason to avoid dairy if you enjoy it
and if your baby is able to tolerate it
in other words i am against this
recommendation to just cut it out of
your diet without any evidence that it
actually needs to be gone however if you
suspect that your baby may have a dairy
allergy or a cow's milk protein
intolerance it's best to have this
confirmed with your pediatrician and to
work with a dietitian on an elimination
and reintroduction strategy alrighty
folks how do things stack up
nutritionally for sam overall i'm not
worried about her macros as they all do
look pretty much in order and it doesn't
sound like she's intentionally
restricting any food groups however i do
want a flag that we only really saw her
have a snack and two meals in this
wedding in a day so her total caloric
intake is sitting at around 900 calories
that is just not enough for a
breastfeeding mama like her i mean even
if she wasn't breastfeeding this
wouldn't be nearly enough calories even
in a caloric deficit for weight loss
so
yeah i'm a wee bit concerned over here
about that also because sam is not
getting enough calories to support her
own needs never mind that of her babies
she's consequently also not getting
enough fiber
and that to me is kind of ironic
considering this is a gut health video
so she's also only meeting around 48 of
her calcium needs which means that her
body is going to be pulling from sam's
bone stores to ensure that her baby has
enough from her breast milk
lastly sam is getting around 50 grams of
protein here which for a regular
non-lactating person would maybe be
sufficient in some cases but
breastfeeding mamas would need much more
than that basically she's actually
deficient in a lot of nutrients but i'm
just mentioning some of these big ones
that are concerned for a mom feeding
another human being as for gentle
nutrition recommendations
ultimately
i would say there's just not enough food
in this day depending on how much sam is
nursing she would likely need an
additional 300 to 500 calories per day
on top of her usual energy needs
this means that she would need to almost
double or triple her calorie intake so
that she's getting closer to the 22 2300
calories per day mark or even more
depending on her activity level so i
would definitely suggest having a solid
breakfast in there which she skipped
entirely and then adding in an extra
snack or two throughout the day
also i know she mentioned spacing out
her meals for good digestion but it's
totally possible to still enable the
migratory motor complex while having
like a snack or two in there
we really only need between two and
three hours between those meals it
doesn't need to be an aggressive five or
six
so assuming she's up at the crack of
dawn like most of us moms hello 5am
wake-up call
uh there's definitely some time in the
day for more eating episodes i know moms
get so busy and it becomes hard to feed
ourselves so that's why i'm just kind of
giving her the benefit of the doubt here
that that's what's happening and she's
not purposefully eating 900 calories and
that's it but we need to prioritize
feeding ourselves enough and that's why
in cases like this i really do urge
against things like intermittent fasting
because it just whittles down the eating
opportunities and it makes it just too
difficult for people to meet their
nutrient and caloric needs more
specifically considering that sam is
breastfeeding we would really want to
keep an eye on her fiber protein and
calcium intake while also significantly
bumping up her overall food intake so
that she's got enough calories to
support her milk supply
i understand society puts a lot of
pressure on us women to get our body
back after we give birth
but i actually always suggest moms wait
until they've fully weaned to take on
any intentional weight loss strategies
your body is still in recovery mode that
whole first year so please
give it some grace patience and time
ultimately we need to start normalizing
appreciating the
after body of postpartum life it's a new
body it is a beautiful body it's a
miraculous superstar body like it grew a
freaking human and for moms like sam
it's still feeding that human as it
grows why is moms would we ever want to
revert back to what existed before that
amazing experience the after body is an
amazing thing so
please do keep that top of mind finally
when it comes to gut health besides her
probiotic recommendation i would
definitely recommend a more holistic
approach by prioritizing sleep managing
stress exercise staying hydrated eating
enough fiber and also being aware of any
potential food intolerances and
sensitivities
eating too little can also put your body
into a state of stress which shoots
cortisol levels up and can actually
negatively impact digestion so making
sure that we are actually nourishing our
body and staying well fed can have a
huge beneficial impact as well
also cutting out most carbs at a fear
that they cause bloating feels
unnecessarily restrictive to me
if sam is experiencing digestive
distress from carb rich meals i
definitely suggest working with a
dietitian on a fodmap elimination trial
to determine exactly which foods and how
much are causing the issue finally let's
chat super briefly about sam's
relationship with food now i get the
impression that sam's approach to food
and eating comes from a place of
genuinely wanting to optimize her health
not only for herself but of course also
for the benefit of her baby
she's not fully following any extreme
diet or restricting entire food groups
or giving up the foods that she loves or
enjoys and aside from a little clean
eating rhetoric or the 80 20 or talking
about carbs causing her bloating and
things like that
i don't see a ton of problematic
information in this video at least
it does seem like she's genuinely trying
to find a pattern of eating that feels
good to her and is also willing to be
somewhat flexible with it like in the
sense that she says she's still gonna
have pizza now while she isn't making
any major unsubstantiated claims in
these videos
i do worry that she may be headed down
the wrong path as evidence of her last
recent video on intermittent fasting
which we actually just caught wind of
literally an hour before i started
filming this so yes note that i record
my videos very far in advance and we
didn't catch this until i was literally
talking right now but very quickly my
first major red flag here is that she's
getting her information about
intermittent fasting protocols from dr
axe's podcast featuring gweny's bff dr
will cole who is the author of the
controversial intuitive fasting book
which i called out in my video right
here
so that alone should be cause for
concern
and probably why sam considers
intermittent fasting to be an intuitive
way to reduce calories and speed up the
metabolism
i
just don't understand that at all
now i break down the research on
intermittent fasting in my video here if
you want a full recap but what i will
say is that while intermittent fasting
can certainly work for some people and
emerging research shows that it may have
some additional health benefits
i really do want to caution where sam is
getting her information from
and unfortunately people like dr axe and
dr will cole
cannot be relied upon to provide
information rooted in scientific
research
so hopefully sam can reevaluate some of
her assumptions around intermittent
fasting as well as food for digestion
and weight loss to give herself a better
opportunity to meet her nutrient and
caloric goals and that my friends is all
that i have for you guys today if you
like this video be sure to give it the
thumbs up leave me a comment below on
who you'd like to review next thank you
again to billbar for sponsoring this
video do not forget to subscribe and
i'll see you next time on abby's kitchen
bye
and for more great videos like this
check out the links right here
you